the British government is unveiling new
technology designed to remove extremist
material from the internet the software
aims to stop the objectionable content
before it goes online here in the u.s.
there is concern that the government is
losing the battle to keep terrorism off
the web
here's correspondent Jillian Turner as
paramedics rushed to treat victims in
New York City's Halloween terror attack
experts were quick to warn lawmakers
about Isis connections in real time as
the attack was unfolding there has been
an explosion of chatter during this
hearing which suggests there may be a
link to Islamic state and recent events
that just unfolded during this hearing
in New York now rising concern about an
uptick in jihadist activity on social
media officials warning Isis and
al-qaeda are spreading propaganda more
effectively than ever before and
accelerating their activation of Western
cells one of the things that the FBI is
increasingly concerned about is that
we've seen what they called the flash to
bank time condense which means the time
that individuals are becoming exposed to
this type of content and the time it
takes them to sort of launch and carry
out the attack it's shrinking American
and European lawmakers now demand action
from Google YouTube Twitter and Facebook
saying it's time to step up and take
responsibility for their content but in
hearings on both sides of the Atlantic
these high tech giant's insists they're
doing all they can to curtail jihadist
activity emphasizing new programs and
technologies meant to stymie terrorist
messaging and recruitment are now at 98%
of the content we have removed for
violent extremism has been identified by
our algorithms that number varies from
policy to policy depending on how
effective and precise the technology is
on particular issues one former senior
intelligence official in both the Obama
and Trump administrations cautions that
government and social media companies
have a shared responsibility they own
the responsibility in the first instance
for policing their their own network we
and the government can do a better job
of providing information to them so that
they know what they're looking for and
they know what the signs and indicators
are with the u.s. decimating Isis's
Caliphate on the Graham
in Iraq and Syria all eyes are now on
cyberspace the new frontier in the war
on terrorism
Brett Jillian thank you